quand tu vois en fait ça passe bien pour
laurent ce sont les derniers préparatifs
avec son logisticien il fait un dernier
tour du bateau sur cette galette de 16
mètres qui prendra le départ pour sa
première route du rhum c'est top voila
voila mais je crois qu'on est bien pour
cette course en solitaire il a fallu
entièrement adapté et remanié ce bateau
destiné à l'origine pour la croisière
il est vraiment prêt pour travaux
traverser l'atlantique après faire la
course c'est chacun fait sa course en
fait ma course à moi avec ce bateau là
les autres car laurent lui prend le
départ pour inciter les gens à arrêter
de fumer
kinésithérapeute à tour est spécialisé
dans le domaine respiratoire
il connaît bien les méfaits du tabac
cette course il a fera donc à son rythme
surtout que sa goélette de conception
ancienne fêtera cette année ses 40 ans
c'est un bateau qui est difficile à
régler donc voila mais bon il y arrivera
parce que il fait ça pour une bonne
cause donc plus tard bon marin il
connaît bien ça il connaît bien le monde
de la voile car cette goélette en course
l'europe devra la main d'oeuvre est tout
seul icéo winch au moins trois à quatre
voile prendre des ris en cas de coup de
vent un engagement et un effort physique
important
laurent a dû se préparer voilà six mois
qu'il s'entraîne intensément
il a aussi fait une dizaine de sorties
en mer par tous les temps pour tester la
solidité du bateau et de ses équipements
il est plutôt plus sécurité par force
évident que les bateaux de course parce
que il encaisse mieux le vent par contre
le problème c'est les vagues ont la peau
gérer les vagues qui arrête le bateau et
faut arriver à passer dans les vagues
sont tapés quoi et donc
comme il pèse 1 tonne c'est dès qu'il
est arrêté à vendre des maris mais
plusieurs vagues donc la différente et
qnx et saint laurent et brera qui pointe
à pitre en guadeloupe en moins de 30
jours
mais pour lui l'essentiel n'est pas là
c'est route du rhum il l'a fait avant
tout pour redonner du souffle et de
l'espoir à tous ceux qui sont accros à
la nicotine